two black lawmakers were expelled from
Tennessee's legislature Democratic
Representatives Justin Jones and Justin
Pearson were removed by Republicans for
taking part in a pro-gun control protest
inside the house chamber last week the
protest followed the Nashville school
shooting that left six dead a third
Democrat Gloria Johnson escaped
expulsion by just one vote protesters at
the state capitol denounced the vote and
President Biden called it shocking on
Democratic and without precedent here's
why the three Democrats had their seats
on the line last week's protest on the
state house floor with a bullhorn they
were angry about the lack of debate over
gun laws after the slaughter at
Nashville's Covenant School last week a
state in which the Ku Klux Klan was
founded
is now attempting another Power grab by
silencing the two youngest black
Representatives